one of the most powerful storms to hit
the us
but this time it slammed into people
sheltering from a pandemic
half a million residents were told to
evacuate
warned they wouldn't survive the storm
surge
as hurricane laura lifted the
destruction emerged
along with a worrying number of people
who'd opted to stay
some had chosen to ride out the storm
than risked the virus
others like kevin have lost their
livelihoods in this pandemic
and didn't have the money to leave
safely at one point in time i had to
cover my wife's body with my own
to show her from from harm you know i
don't want anything to happen to her
so why did you not evacuate
dumb just ignorance
i didn't listen to the signs i kept on
saying it's not going to be that bad
it's not going to be that bad
and then i was wrong it was
that bad the national guard are now
searching for survivors from the air and
from the road
after stranded people made calls for
help but conditions had been too
dangerous to attempt rescue the storm
surge was far less severe than forecast
but fierce winds have left devastation
everywhere you look here nothing is
untouched people here say storm laura
was far more frightening than
storm rita that hit 15 years ago but
this time
far fewer people evacuated covid
has complicated everything kate cotton's
father's restaurant was hit by the
devastation of storm rita
now her restaurant has been hit too
but this time business has already been
battered
by covid19 we were already struggling
with the virus
and you know because it's so small
our capacity is 40 people anyway and
we're down to 10. um
so we're just real really hoping to get
running soon and be able to feed the
first responders
residents now also face the threat of a
chemical fire
caused by the storm while the search for
survivors
continues and people who've lost
everything
somehow seek shelter from a pandemic